My ex-boyfriend, Nick,
I really do have his
name tattooed back there.
Do you know how hard it is to get laid
with another man's name on your back?
(audience laughs)
Not hard.
(upbeat music)
I was dating a guy for a while.
He looked at me and he said,
"It's just that my therapist told me
that I could tell you that
I was more attracted to you
when you were exercising
and eating better,"
and I thought is your
therapist your friend, Sean?
I picked up a bunch of condoms
'cause I'm the breadwinner
of most of my relationships.
That always cracks me
up when a dude chimes in
with like she trapped me with a baby.
You have the missing
ingredient, and we love to bake.
♪ Got, got, got, got, got me goin' crazy ♪
It's more of a man's
game, the happy ending.
Have any women here been
offered a happy ending?
Just an angry silence, okay.
(audience cheers)